13 veterans were given brand new quilts  today this happened at Hebron off Las  Vegas Boulevard it was in partnership  with the quilts of Valor with just serve  a coalition partner of the 911 National  Day of Service and Remembrance the event  allowed the veterans to share stories of  their service and receive a quilt that  represented their story  it was great like so we're not forgotten  sometimes you feel forgotten but we're  not forgotten with the help of these  ladies here I'm very honored and I just  thank God for so many beautiful women  and uh support to show the honor for the  Vets now for more information on the  organization you can check out their  website justserve.com